good to see you sir how are you i'm good
how are you very good this is super
exciting i'm not sure how exciting it is
for you at this juncture but for us
who've been waiting for it for a long
time we're really really stoked man
you know i imagine with every project
you do there's a mixture of nerves and
excitement but what were the biggest
things about coming back to star wars
that put butterflies in your stomach
well it is it's very exciting for me too
being you know two weeks away from when
everyone gets to see it for the first
time i'm i'm super excited about it
because it's been a long time you know
since we finished episode three in 2003
it's been a long journey to get to this
point where we're about to
give the fans a new story you know uh
with obi-wan kenobi
at the heart of that which is lovely for
me
and everything about it was exciting and
nerve-wracking i suppose before we
started
i've got big shoes to fill in that i'm
playing the role that alec guinness
created in the 70s and
he's one of the greatest living well was
one of the greatest living british
actors
of all time and uh
certainly a hero of mine so the fact
that i get to play
the younger hymn is a huge uh privilege
but at the same time
i've got i've got to get it right you
know i don't want to
i don't want to do badly by him but
listen i was in really great hands with
deborah chow
our amazing director of this series who
directed all of the episodes so really
it was like we made a six-hour long
movie and um that's how it felt when we
were shooting it i got the privilege of
working along with her through the
preparation as well you know because i
was involved as a producer from the
start
it's been a lovely journey to to be here
just about to release it to the world
which which will be exciting in a couple
of weeks what was
the emotion like that first day back on
set with hayden that was very special i
couldn't figure out why there were so
many people on set i i turned up on set
because we've been shooting for a little
while before hayden started and there's
just hundreds of people there like uh
standing around the set and
i couldn't quite fit they're all
standing behind the cameras were behind
me and there was a hundred people
standing behind me too and i was
thinking that's weird and then
deborah shouted action and of course
vader appeared at the end of the street
you know and that's i went oh yeah of
course that's why everyone's here they
came to you know the day one with with
darth vader on set was was a big deal
there was a like a real the lovely thing
about making these shows now is that
they're the a lot of the crew are like
real proper star wars fans and they've
ended up working in cinema because they
love star wars and they've ended up
working on star wars because they love
star wars and so you get a real buzz
from the crew which is really nice you
had mentioned big shoes to fill in the
form of alex's shoes but you're also
kind of filling in
your own shoes
because you're in the middle of both of
those versions of the character
is the treatment that you've got with
this uh version of obi-wan in line with
the vision that you might have had
of what he was doing in between all
those years you know before this became
a real thing i don't think i thought
about it when i i certainly didn't think
about it when i was making the original
prequels i think by the time we got to
the end of episode three
i pretty much was finished with it you
know i i love being part of star wars i
i love being part of this huge sort of
legend but they were so technical to
make and the
we had an enormous amount of green
screen and blue screen which i find very
difficult you know it's it's hard in
episode two i spend a lot of time off on
my own on this journey where i discover
the clone army's being made and i'm i'm
with these tall
alien people who
who of course weren't there so i spent
just an enormous amount of time
walking around i mean weeks walking
around a blue set
acting to a tennis ball on a stick or
maybe even not a tennis ball in the
stick just to thin air and it's it's
technically very difficult it's quite
hard to do
so i think by the time it ended in 2003
i was like okay
thank you very much i'll see you later
and um it's only really once i started
feeling the appreciation for those films
because at the time when they came out
they were
seemingly not liked very much the
critics didn't weren't very kind about
our films and that's sort of the taste
that was left in my mouth was it was a
negative one from them but over the
years that have passed since then i've
realized i've met a lot of people who
were kids when we made those films
really who we were making them for
and i realized there's this love for the
prequels from the generation we made
them for who for them our star wars
films are their star wars films and that
that means a lot to me so
that's been nice over the years to start
to feel that even if it's years later
very cool